brian weathers ah there's no place like
home ryan wellers likes pitching here at
petco park so for the left-hander making
his 10th start
21-year-old ryan weather is set to make
his 16th major league appearance of the
season
as i mentioned his 10th start you know
ryan became the first padres pitcher in
history to allow no more than three runs
across his first
six major league starts opponents only
hitting 217 off the young left-hander
soto hitting at 274. nine doubles a
triple nine homers and 38 runs batted in
it's swinging a ground ball into the
ship down in right field solo trying to
beat this play out and he does on the
throw from the third baseman manny
machado we talked about this last night
in the overshift they put him way out in
right field and you know what soto had a
ground ball and he hit it slowly through
the hole into right field there really
wasn't much more machado can do than
that he charged in he backhanded it he
whipped the throw and he wasn't in time
and machado knew it when he let the
throw goal that he wasn't going to get
him so a base hit to keep it moving here
in the top of the first inning corona
first he's got him picked off soto stuck
between first and second hosper chases
him down throws the quarterback he's out
of the baseline the ending is over the
sixth time this year that weathers has
thrown over to first base and gotten a
guy leaning the wrong direction so eric
fetty welcomed back to the rotation
three career games two starts against
san diego
great to see eric back on the mound good
sinking fastball 94 to 95 miles an hour
here comes the birthday boy happy
birthday to manny machado 29th birthday
today here's a chopper left side turner
bare hands throws to first
first to retire the side
what a play by trey turner on a chopper
towards shorty charged in and grabbed it
bare-handed as it turns out that's the
only way he could have gotten machado on
now one on for john gomes catcher who
has caught the first two games of this
four-game series down the left-field
line and that is gonna be a fair ball
and it bangs around in the corner
heading for third is castro and beyond
he'll be waved in here comes a throw
from fernando he will be very out
perfectly executed not even close and
donny what was he very out you can't run
on him
mvp chance for a relay you don't hear
that everywhere here's josh harrison two
outs runner on second after that there's
a drive to left field off the bound of
harrison moving back his profile on the
dirt of the track he will leap and make
the catch against the wall
profar says no
showed off the athleticism and the
padres flash leather and arm strength
here in the second as the nationals do
not score betty looking for his first
hit oh for 11. one and two a swing and a
miss that is the first strike out of
this game by anybody
so top of the order alcitis escobar oh
for one and he strikes him out second
straight strikeout for ryan weathers and
a one two three third inning
carratini at third tatis junior across
the diamond at first pitch to kona work
there he goes pitches
for fernando
there are jumps and then there's this it
was a change up and gomes just puts it
in his back pocket and stolen base
number 19 for fernando tati's junior
breaks a tie with trey turner
and takes the national league lead
second and third with two down padres
hoping cronenworth can deliver here
swinging a ground ball chopped right
side backhand try escobar the jump throw
to first in time for the out nice
playoff cd's escobar and fetty is out of
trouble in the third inning that's the
end of the inning and a great defensive
play by alcitis escobar as the padres
get a couple of hits in the third tati
steals a bag but they leave them both in
scoring position so runners on the
corners nobody out for will myers will
has flown to center oh for one meyers
hits a five ball to right field and deep
soto going back and that ball is gone
three run home run for will myers
opposite field shot and the padres lead
it three to nothing
home run number 10 of the year for will
myers it's been a while since we've seen
that stroke from will myers that
patented right center field
stroke gets a pitch up in the zone here
and gets into it
along with that right center field
stroke we haven't seen that pose in
quite some time
he held it nicely on that
three-run lead
padre
second and third nobody out josh
harrison this is the first jam that
weathers has had to deal with in his
outing creona harrison swung on into the
air to deep center field this is way
back grisham to the wall it is gone
goodbye
align drive three run homer over the
center field wall for josh harrison
has tied this game
bang zoom goes harrison with his fifth
home run of the year
a three-run shot on a 3-0 pitch to dead
center
409 feet the estimated distance
it's the nationals three in the padres
three two one one away and here comes
manny machado andres are three for six
with runners in scoring position tonight
and nobody's gonna hire
ops in this spot then manny machado and
he lines one into right center field
grisham is going to come around
he will score manny machado on his
birthday drives in a go ahead and run
for the padres
happy birthday manny it's 4-3 san diego
at his best when he's using the right
center part of the field it's exactly
what he does here lines a base hit right
over the outstretched glove of escobar
padres regained the lead now the lefty
sam clay on to face hosmer runners on
the corners one out through the right
side and right feel the base set for
hosmer
belterworth will score
the third goes machado padres take a 5-3
lead hosmer drives in a run
the fryer up by a pair and once again
runners at the corners myers hits it in
the air off the end of the bat to right
field soto going back towards the corner
he will make the catch manny is tagging
on his way home the throw will be cut
and a sacrifice fly for will myers his
fourth run bad at end of the night and
now a six to three padre lead here in
the fifth the nationals come up they
trail by three now juan soto swinging a
high fly ball left center field this is
deep back on it grisham to the warning
track at the wall he's out of room and
it's gone solo gets under one and he's
finally made it to ten homers and the
nets take care of one of that deficit
soto homeward last inning his tenth of
the year runner at second is hernandez
runner at first is escobar swinging in a
miss got him with a fastball up in the
zone and for the second straight night
tim hill strikes out juan soto as jake
cronin worth will dig in
against machado this one is belted to
left center field toward the gap chasing
robles into a dive and he caught it
headlong diving catch on the backhand
for robles
robbing cronin worth of extra bases
machado tipping his cap out in roble's
direction
a gold glove play by robles padres have
manny machado on second base two down
will myers at the dish will has driven
in four of the six padre runs tonight
myers yanks it into left field corner
from second comes machado
padres take a 7-4 lead will myers drives
in his fifth run of the night
two down in the ninth for trey turner
fly ball right field myers going back
onto the track to make the catch and
ends the ball game a one two three ninth
inning for mark malanson who records the
save as the padres take game two of the
series